Settle down. I do want to draw your
attention to the fact that the final
exam schedule is out.
It has been out for about a week.
And the 3.091 final will be on
Wednesday of finals week,
which puts it on the morning of the
15th of December.
It will be a three-hour
extravaganza, a celebration of
learning where you all come to show
you what you have mastered.
And it is going to be just a grand,
grand time.
And it will be over in the Johnson
Athletic Center.
I urge you to take a look at the
final exam schedule and make your
travel plans, as soon as you know
what your last obligation is.
Because things are going to get
booked, and it is going to be harder
and harder to get out of here,
certainly to get out at a decent
price. Last day we looked at
Electron Domain Theory which allowed
us to predict the shapes of
molecules. And this is
taken from the book.
This is Table 4.
. And I have highlighted in orange.
We worked through some of these
molecules last day,
the SF6, BrF5, ICl4-.
And then we looked at the series
CH4, SF4, ICl4-,
and we saw how by counting the
number of electron domains and then
partitioning them into bonding
versus nonbonding domains we could
proceed in a systematic manner
towards the deduction of what the
molecular shape should be.
So that was a productive day.
And I urge you to understand what
is going on in Table 4.
. You can expect that you will be
tested on that at the end of October.
You will have an aid sheet so you
will probably want to know how to
work through this document here.
Today I wanted to continue this
treatment of covalent compounds.
And specifically I wanted to talk
broadly about how we determine state
of aggregation.
In other words,
how do we determine whether
something is going to be a solid or
a liquid or a gas?
We have already seen that ionic
compounds, by their nature,
because they have unsaturated bonds
and they continue to allow more ions
to glom onto the initial starting
point results in a large aggregate,
tightly bound, leads to crystal
formation.
The crystal is the regularity,
but definitely solid formation.
And when you are trying to answer
the question is something a solid or
a liquid or a gas under certain
conditions, this is the subliminal
message. You have to compare the
cohesive forces versus the
disruptive forces.
So the cohesive forces are the
binding forces and the disruptive
forces typically are
thermal in origin.
We have to compare the binding
energy of the substance to the
general thermal energy.
And that is shown here.
Binding energy, then that gets back
to the nature.
If it is an ionic compound,
this binding energy is that Madelung
bearing crystal lattice energy,
and it is very negative. For sodium
chloride it is about 787 kilojoules
per mole. Whereas,
the thermal energy in this room is
about a 40th of an electron volt.
That is small. Sodium chloride is
a crystal at room temperature.
Now I want to turn to covalent
compounds and ask the same question.
What is the state of aggregation?
But there is a fork in the road here.
There are two types of covalent
compounds. We saw,
as is shown up here on the slide,
the results when we have just the
single molecules.
But we also saw, at the end of last
lecture, it is also possible to talk
about covalent networks.
We looked at diamond and we looked
at graphite.
Now, in the case of diamond and
graphite, we are in a situation that
is similar to ionic solids.
In other words, we have large
aggregates because the sp3
hybridization allows for carbon to
bond to carbon to bond to carbon to
bond to carbon.
And so you end up with a large
aggregate. In fact,
it is an ordered aggregate.
It is a crystal. Diamond is a
crystal, just as sodium chloride is
a crystal, but both of them are
large aggregates.
And we saw also that the binding
energy in diamond is
very, very strong.
Very strongly negative.
And so, therefore, it trumps the
thermal energy of the system.
So these are solids at room
temperature. How about molecules?
That's what I want to focus on
today. What is the nature of
binding in molecular systems?
And specifically let's just take
one of the molecules we looked at
last day. We looked at sulfur
hexafluoride. And I told you,
sulfur hexafluoride is a gas at room
temperature, even though this thing
has a very, very high
molecular weight.
The question we are really asking is
what are the forces that would cause
sulfur hexafluoride to bind to
itself? And so far what we have
been looking at,
electron domain theory,
doesn't answer this question at all.
Electron domain theory treats what
is going on inside the molecule.
It treats intramolecular bonding.
This is between sulfur and fluorine.
And this is a very strong reaction
and is referred to as a primary bond
because it is the first bond that
forms. If I look at the world from
the vantage point of sulfur,
the first bond sulfur encounters is
this primary bond to its neighboring
flourines. But now I want to ask
how does this molecule,
which we know is net neutral,
bond to another one like it?
That now means we have to shift,
so state of aggregation is not
determined by this at all.
State of aggregation is determined
by intermolecular forces.
And they are different. What we
want to do is look at the
intermolecular forces.
And, for that,
we are going to go through this
catalog. That's last day.
This is what we are going to do.
We are going to go through this
catalog. I am going to show you
four different types of
intermolecular forces,
and I am going to go about them
systematically.
The first one is dipole-dipole
interactions.
And, clearly, this interaction
occurs only between polar molecules.
Involves polar molecules.
These molecules have a net dipole
moment. We could model them as
dipoles. And so if this is,
for example, an isolated molecule of
hydrogen chloride,
we know we have a strong covalent
bond within the molecule and we know
the shape of the molecule.
It is linear.
But how does this hydrogen chloride
bond to another hydrogen chloride?
Well, we can see that this is delta
minus, this is delta plus,
and so this delta minus end is
attracted to the delta plus end of
an adjacent molecule and so on and
so on. So this is a dipole-dipole
interaction that,
when the temperature is low enough,
the thermal energy will not disrupt
the bonds that are forming by this
dipole-dipole interaction.
So it is operative at low
temperature. And these are all weak
interactions. Everything I am going
to talk about today is weak by an
order of magnitude in comparison to
the primary reactions.
If we compare ionic bonding and
primary covalent bonding with this
sort of thing,
this is down at around on the order
of about 10 kilojoules per mole.
Whereas, up here we are talking
about hundreds of kilojoules per
mole. These are very weak,
which means that at room temperature
HCl is a gas, sodium chloride and
diamond are solids.
And the energy in a dipole-dipole
interaction, I am not going to give
you the full formula,
but I will just give you what it is
proportional to.
Clearly, it is going to be
proportional to the strength
of the dipole.
Stronger dipoles will bond more
tightly than weaker dipoles.
And, in fact, it goes as the fourth
power of the dipole moment.
If mu is the dipole moment,
stronger dipole moments give much,
much stronger interactions than
weaker dipole moments.
And a dipole moment is proportional
to what? It is proportional to the
charge and the separation.
If I have more charge separated by
a greater distance,
I construct a greater dipole,
a dipole of greater strength.
And in the denominator we have the
cube root of the interdipole
separation. Really,
what we want is very strong dipoles
spaced closely together to give us
the strongest reaction.
The example HCl, I have used this
in some of my own research.
This thing has a melting point --
HCl has a melting point minus 115
degrees C, and the boiling point at
atmospheric pressure is minus 85
degrees C. If we go down below
minus 115 degrees,
see, the thermal energy is low
enough that at temperatures below
this value this weak interaction
dominates and we have solid HCl.
Second form of interaction --
And these are all cataloged in
Chapter 8 of your book,
this one here is a little bit
premature, but all the books do it
so I will just,
for completeness,
go through it. It is really
involving solutions.
This one was HCl to HCl.
It is answering the question under
what circumstances is HCl,
solid, liquid or gas? This one here
is called dipole-induced dipole.
This is really two different
species. You can see in the cartoon
that the left has HCl,
hydrogen chloride, and the right has
argon.
So this is bonding between two
different types of species.
For example, if I were to mix HCl,
which a gas at room temperature.
Argon is a gas at room temperature.
I mix two gases at room temperature,
I have a gas. But at low enough
temperatures, I will get a liquid.
And, at low enough temperatures yet,
I will get a solid.
It will be essentially a solid
alloy of HCl molecules
and argon atoms.
What holds that together?
Whenever you see a solid,
you must conclude that there are
forces that bind the species
together. Things don't just sit
there because they are lazy.
They are bound. What are the
forces that could bind a condensed
form of argon and HCl together?
And the answer is dipole-induced
dipole interactions.
This is a bit of a departure,
but it will come in handy in a
little bit. This is present in
solutions of what?
You need one polar and nonpolar
species. They could be atoms or
they could be molecules,
it doesn't matter. So how does this
work?
Well, here is the nonpolar molecule.
This is argon, helium or one such
methane. Nonpolar.
So it has uniform distribution,
by definition. If it is nonpolar
there is no net dipole.
Here is the nonpolar entity,
nonpolar species. If I bring up a
dipole in close proximity,
what can happen is the following.
This negative end of the dipole
interacts with the electron cloud in
the nonpolar species so
as to cause repulsion.
This cloud, it's in motion,
the electrons are not potted,
and so the presence of this negative
end of the dipole actually causes
the electrons to flee.
We get a maldistribution in the
electrons. And,
in fact, this end becomes a little
bit electron lean,
electron deficient,
and the other end becomes electron
rich.
What started off minding its own
business with this symmetric
distribution of electrons in the
presence of the dipole takes on a
dipole moment itself.
So this dipole is induced by the
presence of the permanent dipole.
And now we have some bonding. This
negative end here now is in a
position to be attracted to the
positive end of a permanent dipole
and so on and so on.
This is how the system operates.
And we know that the energy of the
dipole-induced dipole interaction
goes as one over the square of the
interpolar separation.
This is one over the square of the
Whereas, here it is one over the
cube of the interpolar separation.
And, furthermore, we can talk about
how susceptible elements
are to this induction.
I can give you two different
elements. Suppose I have argon,
and next to it I will put helium.
They both have inert gas electron
configurations,
but helium is small and has a few
electrons. Argon is large and has
many electrons.
Which of these two,
argon or helium is more susceptible
to this electron displacement?
You see that it is argon because
argon is larger. It's squishier.
It is softer. This is hard.
This is like a baseball. This is
like a Nerf ball.
It can be easily distorted in terms
of its charge.
And we call this distortion of
electrical charge polarization.
Polarization is the official term
for electrical charge displacement.
And so we can quantify the ease with
which electrons are displaced within
a chemical entity by a quantity
called polarizability.
And give it the symbol alpha.
And this is a measure of ease of
electron displacement.
And, clearly, polarizability is
affected by --
Now watch the fonts here.
This is alpha. And then I want to
say alpha is proportional to,
I don't know how you differentiate
the two. Alpha is proportional to
the number of electrons.
In other words, the more electrons
the more there are to move.
If I only have a couple of
electrons and I have a couple of
protons, those electrons are more
tightly bound.
They are less flexible.
So the number of electrons and also
the size.
For equal numbers of electrons,
a larger entity will be softer and
squishier than a smaller entity.
So polarizability scales with
electron number and with size.
We reason that helium is going to
be low polarizability.
Whereas, argon will be high
polarizability.
Because we have a lot of electrons,
they have to, by necessity, you know
what the filling sequence is.
The more electrons you have,
those last electrons are farther out,
so the positive charge in the
nucleus has a weaker hold on them.
Therefore, while they are bound,
they are a little bit friskier.
They don't sit in their place.
They move around.
Now, let's get back to homonuclear
species. This is induced
dipole-induced dipole.
That is the third type of
interaction. Induced dipole-induced
dipole.
This is a really fascinating one.
It puzzled people for a long time.
And it is dominant in nonpolar
molecules. Dominant in nonpolar
everything. It is dominant in
nonpolar species,
atoms and molecules.
And here are some examples.
Let's go back. Here is argon.
Now, if you look on your Periodic
Table, argon has a melting point of
84 Kelvin. And it has a boiling
point of 87 Kelvin.
And I told you, whenever you see a
solid, that you have to conclude
that it is held together by some
force. Let's imagine that we are at
liquid nitrogen temperature.
We take some argon out of an argon
gas cylinder and we flow it through
a tube. And that tube is immersed
in liquid nitrogen.
Liquid nitrogen is 77 Kelvin.
Well, that is below 84.
The argon is going to solidify.
It is going to deposit on the walls
of the tube. And after a while I
will have argon ice.
I am sitting there and looking at
argon ice. What binds argon to
argon? Well, it is not ionic.
It is not primary covalent. It is
not dipole-dipole.
They are all the same.
What could possibly bind argon to
argon?
Was it just adhesion because it is
sticky? Why? Well,
the answer was given to us by a
German scientist by the name of
Fritz London. And London said I
think I can explain this.
He looked back over here at
dipole-dipole and said we have
already come to the conclusion that
electrons are in motion
and are not stationary.
He said imagine if we could zoom in
here with a femtosecond camera and
take a snapshot.
Instead of having a uniform
distribution of electrons,
suppose at this instant in time
there is a slight excess of electron
density here at around 2:00.
Therefore, conservation of charge
dictates that there must be a slight
electron deficiency at 8:00.
Well, if this is the case,
what is the consequence for the
adjacent argon?
Well, this adjacent argon says if
this is electron deficient it is
going to pull electrons in this
argon and make the bottom right here
electron rich leaving the top left
electron deficient which then causes
"she told her and he told him", etc.
So what is the result here?
The result is we have dipoles.
Time averaged, it is nonpolar, but
it is always dipolar.
And this is a tiny, tiny dipole.
He called this the time fluctuating
dipole. And it is present in all
systems. Even a sodium ion has an
electron cloud that is in motion,
and we don't see this in sodium
because the action of this in sodium
is dwarfed by the Coulombic force
which is a thousand times stronger.
But this is the only game in town.
When you are at 77 Kelvin there is
nothing left so this is dominant.
And the force that comes out of
this, this attractive force has been
termed the London Dispersion Force.
And the London Dispersion Force is a
very weak force.
And, as you would expect,
it is proportional to the
polarizability.
Elements that have big electron
clouds that are weakly held are
going to be more mobile than small
atoms that have small electron
clouds that are tightly held.
The London Dispersion energy goes
as the square of polarizability.
And, as you would expect,
it is a very weak force analogous to
the repulsive force.
We are talking about
electron-electron repulsion.
Where did you see that before?
You saw that in the Coulombic
derivation with the Madelung
Constant. That is the Born Exponent.
It is a very high number because
this is a very weak force.
If this is the interspecies
separation, this goes as r to the
6th, which makes sense.
It is sort of Born-like.
Now, this actually has another name.
This is not a secondary bond for
argon. This is the only bond for
argon, so this is a primary bond.
As a primary bond, some people call
this a Van der Waals bond.
It is a time fluctuating dipole
which leads to a London Dispersion
Force resulting in a Van der Waals
bond, which for some systems
is the primary.
And it is not that I cannot spell
Van der Waals.
He was a Dutchman,
and that is how you spell Van der
Waals. Here is the situation.
This is the primary bonding in
argon. Go to your Periodic Table
and look up iodine.
It exists as the diatomic molecule.
It has a melting point of plus 114
degrees C and has a boiling point of
184 degrees C.
Iodine, at room temperature,
is a deep purple crystal. What
holds iodine together?
You're looking at it going,
I know, I am going to go back to
that Table 4.3 and will tell you
about iodine-iodine.
I am going to write the Lewis
structure. That is wrong.
That has nothing to do with it.
How does this iodine bond to
another iodine?
Well, what is the catalog?
Is there a net charge? No.
Is there a local dipole? This is a
homonuclear molecule that is 100%
covalent. What's left?
You have electron clouds here
around the two iodines.
Iodine is big.
It is huge. First of all,
there are lots of electrons.
And they have a giant corral to run
around. And so they are running
around all over the place.
And, at any given moment, the right
side might be a little bit
electron-excessive and the left side
might be a little bit
electron-deficient.
Net neutral of course.
And then that is what causes the
next iodine and the next iodine and
the next iodine.
This is the way you describe.
How about this one? Methane. We
saw methane.
How do I form solid methane?
When you look at Jupiter you are
seeing solid methane.
Do you ever sit there and think,
how is that solid methane held
together? I bet you never thought
about that. Well,
I am inviting you. Think about it.
How does this methane bond to this
methane? I can see everybody go I
know, carbon, hydrogen.
It is a polar bond. I've got it,
it's a polar bond. And you proudly
trot out your electronegativities
and you tell me what the
percent ionicity is.
And I go no, no.
That is wrong. It has nothing to
do with it. I am asking about
foreign policy and you are talking
about some state budget.
I want foreign policy. How do they
negotiate with one another?
Well, what is the list? Net charge?
No, they are neutral.
Dipole? No, they are symmetric.
What is left? Solid methane is
held together by Van der Waals bonds,
London Dispersion Force.
Remember that the next time you look
up at the sky and you see Jupiter.
It is solid methane. Here is a
good example of this in compound.
These are three different
hydrocarbons. It is just carbon and
hydrogen. Here is propane,
octane, eicosane. Look, it is just
CH2, CH2, CH2 with methyl terminals.
So they are net neutral.
There is no dipole moment.
They are symmetric molecules.
And you all know what propane is.
It is a gas at room temperature.
It is used as a low-grade fuel,
boils at minus 42. Octane is the
principle constituent of gasoline,
which we know is a liquid at room
temperature. And eicosane is a
solid. It looks like paraffin.
Three different molecules, all
nonpolar. How do I describe the
fact that propane is a gas,
octane is a liquid and eicosane is a
solid?
Right here. Polarizability,
which is proportional to the number
of electrons inside.
As these molecules get bigger,
the electrons have a bigger corral
to run around in.
It is sort of like a small tank
gives rise to small waves and a big
tank gives rise to big waves.
And that is what you are seeing.
Big waves mean bonds. Small waves
means the thermal forces present at
room temperature disrupt.
That is a good one.
I really like that.
That's a vivid one.
Actually, this is out of your book.
This is the whole series. I just
chose a few extremes.
Here is methane, ethane,
propane, butane, on and on and on.
And as the molecule weight
increases the boiling point
increases. Why?
Because the polarizability is
increasing. But I don't want
anybody telling me that the reason
something has a higher boiling point
is it has a higher molecular weight.
That is not expository.
It is not mass. It is about
polarizability,
because mass alone will not get you
the time-fluctuating dipole.
That is what is shown up here.
And now the fourth one. The fourth
type of secondary bonding
is hydrogen bonding.
And it occurs between,
as the name implies, hydrogen and
only the most electronegative
elements. And that is fluorine,
oxygen and nitrogen owing to their
high average valence electron energy.
There is something peculiar here
about the combination of high
average valence electron energy and
the lightest element.
And here is what I want you to
first be reminded of.
I am showing here that average
valence electron energy in order.
And we see fluorine has the highest
of the active.
I know neon has a higher,
but neon doesn't participate in
chemical reactions to speak of.
I know there are subtle differences
in the electronegativity scales.
One of them has fluorine at 3.98.
This has it at 4.19. It is a
self-consistent set.
So what do we see? Here we are up
at around 20 electron volts for
average valence electron energy,
and then it tapers off.
Something magical happens at around
18 electron volts.
What happens? When we put hydrogen
in the presence of something that is
that strongly electronegative,
so let's work with the most powerful
example, fluorine.
Hydrogen donates its electron to
the covalent bond.
Fluorine donates one of its seven
valence electrons.
And here are the other six.
And we know because fluorine is
strongly electronegative.
This bond is very polar,
and we can designate the fluorine
end as delta negative and the
hydrogen end as delta plus.
And let's look at this in greater
detail. When we start pulling hard
on the electron associated with
hydrogen, what is left?
It is not an atom that has its
protons in the nucleus and n minus
one electrons.
In the case of hydrogen,
it only had the one electron.
And when you pull that electron
hard, what you are leaving is
something that is essentially
a proton.
If, hydrogen is denuded of its
electron, it is a proton.
The proton is very special because
the proton has a charge of plus one
but it has a volume that is tiny,
tiny, tiny. So the charge density
is very, very high.
Now let's bring up another HF.
Here is a second HF.
We know that dipole-dipole
interactions happen.
That was category number one.
So let's start with a simple
dipole-dipole interaction.
The negative end of the left HF
molecule sidles up to the positive
end of the right HF molecule.
Then the magic happens. You see
this nonbonding domain sitting here
on the right side?
Those nonbonding electrons are
dangling way, way out there.
And here is this hydrogen over here.
And its electron is being pulled so
hard by the fluorine on the right,
I mean this hydrogen hardly gets
visitation rights to see this
electron. Here are these two
electrons sitting over here,
and hydrogen is looking over there
and said I hardly get any time with
my electron. But there are these
two lone pair electrons sitting
there. And so can you imagine that
there is a force that is set up
between this lone pair of electrons?
Because this fluorine,
because it has so many electrons,
tends to neglect its electrons. It
does not pay close attention.
If you come from a big family,
you don't get as much attention as
if you were an only child.
Fluorine has electrons all around.
If two kind of stray off, fluorine
doesn't care. That is what is
happening. Here is hydrogen that
does not have the full impact of its
single electron.
Here are two electrons dangling way,
way out. This is a recipe
for attraction.
And that is exactly what happens.
And so a weak force is established
between this nonbonding pair and
hydrogen, when hydrogen is found in
a molecule where there is this very,
very strong pull on its lone
electron. The hydrogen bond is
established in this following manner.
And this is a very important bond
because it is found in compounds
involving hydrogen fluorine,
hydrogen oxygen, hydrogen nitrogen.
And let me show you what the
manifestation of this is.
Here is, first of all,
a cartoon from your book that shows
this weak force.
You see the hydrogen where its
electron has been pulled.
In this case, they are showing
water so this is hydrogen-oxygen.
The electron of hydrogen has been
pulled towards oxygen.
And this distance is about 1
angstrom and this is distance is
about 1and ¾ angstroms.
So it is greater. I am not
suggesting that this is a double
bond off the hydrogen,
but it is not something to be
ignored. It is very,
very strong. And, in fact,
it is about twice as strong as the
next strongest force here.
It is about two to four times the
intensity of a dipole-dipole
interaction, so it makes a huge
difference. And let me demonstrate
that with data.
This is a plot that I inked in.
This is out of your book. It shows
the series that I am going to show,
but I kind of like this one because
I had a chance to color.
As you know, that is very
therapeutic for me so I needed to do
this. First thing I want do is I
want to go across the groups and
show you the impact of
hydrogen bonding.
I used colors of the T,
so let's start with Green Line here.
The Green Line is group 14. And
what do we find?
Here is methane,
silane, germane, stannane.
The four tetrahydrides, if you will,
of carbon, silicon,
germanium and tin. And what do you
find? As the size of the molecule
increases, its number of electrons
increases, its polarizability
increases. Therefore,
its induced dipole-induced dipole
interaction increases.
And, therefore,
the greater the atomic mass the
greater the boiling point.
Everything makes sense. Now,
let's go to the next one. The next
one I am going to go over is,
this is group 14, so what I want to
do is go to group 15.
That's the Blue Line.
The Blue Line is up here.
This is stibnite. This is the
antimony compound.
This is arsine, which is the
trihydride of arsenic,
which is used in CVD and precursor
to making gallium arsenide.
They use this over here in Building
13. Occasionally,
you will hear the sirens wailing and
people have to evacuate the building.
It is usually a gas leak of this
stuff. It's good the sirens go off.
It could be worse if they didn't.
And then we have phosphine.
This is following the same trend.
As the size of the molecule shrinks,
the polarizability shrinks.
Therefore, the Van der Waals bond
weakens. By this analogy --
Plus, these are dipole interactions.
These are all trigonal pyramids.
Its sp3 hybridization with a lone
pair, so these all have a net dipole
moment. And the dipole is getting
stronger and stronger according to
this formula. And everything is
going great. All of a sudden
ammonia has got this abnormally high
boiling point.
What is going on?
Well, in the case of ammonia,
it is not just --
Here is ammonia.
It is not just ammonia with its net
dipole moment that is sticking to
other ammonias.
What is happening in the case of
ammonia is when another ammonia gets
in the vicinity hydrogen bonds are
forming. And those hydrogen bonds
swamp everything.
And, therefore, they give strength
to the system that trumps the
thermal energy and thereby raises
the boiling point of ammonia to
values that are higher than
arsine and phosphine.
Let's go to Group 16.
We start with hydrogen telluride,
hydrogen selenide, hydrogen sulfide
fitting the pattern.
Smaller molecules, lower
polarizability,
smaller dipole moments,
everything is fine. Then we get to
H2O and it is up at 100 degrees C
which is higher than even hydrogen
telluride. Why?
Because the hydrogen bonding is
present in water.
It is not present in the compounds
of hydrogen and any of the other
members of this homologous series.
If it were not for hydrogen bonding,
water would not boil at 100 degrees
C, it would not melt at zero degrees
C, and this conversation would take
on a very different character.
We wouldn't exist. So we need
hydrogen bonding.
Lastly, let's look at HI.
This is Group 17. These are just
simple linear molecules.
Hydrogen iodide, hydrogen bromide,
hydrogen chloride. There is our
prototypical hydrogen chloride.
We are just getting bigger and
bigger dipoles,
higher and higher boiling points.
Finally, we get down to HF which
should be the tiniest.
It should have the weakest
interaction. And we have a very,
very abnormally high boiling point
because hydrogen bonding is
operative. You can see hydrogen
bonding and the impact that it has
on boiling point and properties.
And we will return to this when we
talk about conformality in polymers,
in nylons in particular.
And certainly when we get to
biochemistry because our proteins
consist of, among other things,
hydrogen and oxygen and nitrogen.
And those hydrogen bonds help hold
the system together.
At this point, just to summarize,
we have seen three types of primary
bonding. We have seen ionic bonding,
covalent bonding and,
in certain instances, Van der Waals
bonding. And things seem to be
working fairly well, but
then there is data.
And here is some data that I want
you to look at.
These are data of electrical
conductivity. And up here we have
metals, silver at 10 to the 7th
Siemens per centimeter,
copper at 10 to the 7th Siemens per
centimeter. I mentioned last day
that graphite has some delocalized
electrons. It is 10 to the 4th
Siemens per centimeter.
And then we get down to the
insulators. I said diamond was a
good insulator. It is
10 to the minus 11th.
There is aluminum oxide,
a good ionic compound. And here is
PTFE, Teflon, 10 to the minus 16th.
The first thing that you notice is
look at the range.
I mean if you look at the range on
the Periodic Table,
look at the range of something like
density. Lithium has a density of 0.
3, and you have osmium that is
around 22. It is a range of about
40. Look at this.
10 to the 7th, 10 to the minus 16th.
A range of 10 to the 23rd.
Secondly, what do we know about the
compounds we have seen so far?
Ionic compounds, conductors or
insulators? We know they are
insulators. They have tightly bond
electrons in stable octet
configurations,
so that is not going to help us.
Covalent compounds. Well, the
network ones are like diamond,
very, very good insulators. Van der
Waals compounds,
let's look at that.
How about argon? Do you think
argon is going to be a good
conductor of electrons?
No way. It has inert gas
configuration.
Those are the three types of primary
bonding. And I cannot explain how
three-quarters of the Periodic Table
has this abnormally high value of
electrical conductivity.
It sounds to me like we need to
come up with yet another form of
bonding. And the answer is metallic
bonding. Why is it metallic bonding?
Because it is practiced in metals.
Let's look at metallic bonding.
The need for metallic bonding was
brought on by the observation of
electrical conductivity.
If we are going to be true to form
in 3.091, we have to look at the
electronic structure.
And the first model that attempted
to account for the high observed
value of electrical conductivity was
enunciated in 1900 by a German
physicist by the name of Paul Drude.
What he said was he could model a
metal as a mixture of positive
nuclei plus the inner shell
electrons, which he called this
whole mix of the positive nuclei and
all the inner shell electrons,
he called that the atomic core.
And then the valence electrons,
he said, were separate. You have
the atomic core plus valence
electrons which he assumed were free.
That is to say they could move
about the material.
In other words, they were not
associated with any single atom.
We call them delocalized. I think
last day I used the
term delocalized.
And we will come back to that in a
bit. This is,
in essence, modeling the metal as a
solid consisting of cores and the
electrons freely moving,
much in the same way as a gas.
This was termed the free electron
gas model. In other words,
a gas of free electrons. And with
this they had some success.
They were able to account for such
things as the heat capacity of
solids. The heat capacity of solids
they could model.
That was good. And I think there
was something else they were able to
do. But, by and large,
this did not stand up because it was
not quantitative.
If it is not quantitative,
what does that mean right off the
bat? No Nobel prize.
You got it. No Nobel prize for
Paul Drude. No quantitative,
no Nobel prize.
We will just put this here.
"No Nobel." And it is true.
The people that made really
important insights but they were not
quantitative, no Nobel.
So it is not quantitative because
it cannot be tested.
And the second thing is it was not
discriminating.
In other words,
if you said assume that something is
metallic, then you continue with the
atomic core and the gas
of free electrons.
But that is like saying silver is a
metal and this is how a metal
behaves. But what about the earlier
question? Why is silver a metal and
diamond not acting as a metal?
Doesn't diamond have a set of
positive nuclei with inner shell
electrons? Why do you choose to
have the valence electrons of silver
moving around but the valence
electrons of diamond
not moving around?
Well, we know a little bit that he
didn't know because we have the
benefit of Linus Pauling and the
understanding of covalent bonding.
But, even so, he could not help
classify insulators and metals.
And so that did not work. We had
to wait almost 30 years for the next
installment. And so when we return
next day we will look at the next
installment of the attempt to
explain metallic bonding.
And what happens in the 30 years
between 1900 and 1930?
The quantum revolution.
Clearly, in 1900, in respect of
Professor Drude,
absent quantum mechanics,
there was not much else they could
have done. But the next people are
going to stand on the shoulders of
people who gave us quantum mechanics
and explain why we have metals as we
do. Let's take a look at a few
things before we leave.
The unit of conductivity is the
Siemens named after Charles Williams
Siemens who was quite an inventor.
He was born in Germany but spent
most of his life in the UK.
He gave us the open-hearth furnace
which dominated steel-making for a
century, laid the first
trans-Atlantic telegraphy cable in
1985, and something dear to my heart
was an early proponent of electric
traction for automobiles,
no internal combustion engine.
Siemens is this.
And so the unit of Siemens is the
reciprocal of the ohm,
which when I was your age actually
was called the mho.
That is ohm spelled backwards.
This is electrical engineering.
That is supposed to be funny, but
obviously the SI commission decided
mho just does not cut it.
We are going to give it a proper
name with a proper recognition.
And, oddly enough, Ohm, whose unit
is the reciprocal of the Siemens,
was also a professor in Germany.
But, when he enunciated his law in
1827, the linearity between
resistance and the voltage required
to drive a particular current,
he was so badly ridiculed at his
university that he resigned his
position. As I told you in the past,
scientific change does not come
easily. I know Professor Ballinger
talked to you a little bit about
Midgley. I want to talk to you
about one other invention of
Midgley's and refer back to all of
these shapes of molecules.
I call him sp3 Midgley because most
of his work that we know today
involved sp3 hybridized molecules.
And I know Professor Ballinger
talked about Freon which was a
refrigerant. Midgley at one point
joined the Dayton Engineering
Company, which is DELCO,
which eventually was bought by
General Motors.
And in 1921 he discovered this
anti-knock agent for gasoline called
tetraethyl lead.
You know the structure is 6s2p2.
You can hybridize this to give us
6sp3. And there are four unpaired
electrons there.
And then we can take the ethyl
radical and put four of those on.
And so this gets diluted in the
gasoline and goes through the
combustion process.
And what it does is actually
reduces the potency of gasoline.
If the potency of gasoline is too
high, when the fuel first goes into
the combustion chamber and then the
piston compresses,
remember everything is hot from the
previous combustion,
the chamber could explode of its own
accord.
And, if it does so,
it with ram the piston up.
Everything is supposed to be moving
synchronously.
What you want to do is put
something in the gasoline to delay
the combustion until the spark plug
fires. The sad thing is that there
was a superior chemical known
already back in 1920 which was ethyl
alcohol. If ethyl alcohol had been
used, we wouldn't have all the lead
in the environment that we have
thanks to the use of leaded gasoline
for about 50 years.
Anyway. This is tetraethyl lead,
and this was an invention of Midgley.
Now, in the 1970s along came
catalytic converters which we have
to this day. And these are precious
metal catalysts,
platinum, palladium and rhodium.
But when tetraethyl lead burns the
carbon forms CO2,
the hydrogen forms H2O and the lead
forms lead dioxide. And lead
dioxide is volatile.
And it goes with the exhaust gases.
And it will pass over the catalyst.
And the catalyst's job is to break
bonds. And so it breaks the
lead-oxygen bond and reduces it to
lead. And now the lead alloy is
with the catalyst.
Now you have platinum alloying with
lead. What do you think the
catalytic activity of lead is?
Considering the difference in cost,
I am willing to wager that if lead
had any catalytic value we wouldn't
be using platinum.
So when the lead alloys with the
catalyst, it poisons the catalyst.
Hence in the ‘70s the advent of
lead-free fuel.
All of these things came together
as a result of the need to deal with
the absence of the tetraethyl lead
necessitated by the onset of
catalytic converters.
Again you see where the sp3
hybridization comes into play in a
chemical that was used for about two
generations. When it came along,
people thought it was fantastic to
stabilize internal combustion
engines.
In the end it was dismissed for its
toxicity to the environment.
The same thing happened with Freon
12, dismissed after two generations
for its toxicity to the environment.
Midgley died about 30 years ago.
He doesn't know any of this.
OK. We will see you Friday.